[Música]
antes de começar o queria perguntar pra
vocês quem começou o dia hoje sem ter
nenhuma influência com um alguma fonte
de energia independente com aquela forro
foi dormir sem o celular do lado tocando
mandando uma mensagem para alguém eu
acho que isso é muito difícil na
realidade toda a humanidade desde o
começo da humanidade
a base social política estratégica e
tomada de decisão está voltada à energia
isso é um tema além de ser estratégico e
complexo pode ser discutido em umas
quatro cinco horas que não é o caso do
tempo do ted mas que a gente poderia
discutir em várias vertentes como de
políticas públicas de política
energética ou num vilarejo com relação
ao acesso à energia então todo mundo
gira em torno de uma necessidade básica
de acesso à energia e não por isso
identificar a maior fonte de energia que
a gente tenha maior fonte de energia que
realmente persiste em nossas vidas desde
o começo que é o sol e se o sol que nos
proporcionou basicamente um presente que
o homem indentificado desde o começo
poucas pessoas sabem que a maior fonte
de energia renovável hoje em dia por
questões estratégicas ea madeira
todo mundo relaciona a energia renovável
como com uma fonte estratégica prade
diminuição do carbono e outros fatores
relacionados à diminuição de
descarbonização do planeta
porém se ele pensa estrategicamente como
a madeira
realmente tem essa participação porque
ouvi falar muito de óleo fica old solar
painel fotovoltaico maremotriz em alguns
países geotérmico em outros mas utiliza
madeira um pouco primitivo que nem nosso
amigo aqui ancestral nós naquela época
eu eu me coloco na situação dele de
imaginar primeiro momento de não ter
essa facilidade de ter acesso à energia
ou de calor e num primeiro momento se
deparar com um presente do sol que foi
sintetizado por uma árvore pela planta
essas reações eletroquímicas que
concentraram carboidratos dentro dessa
madeira e que proporcionou o primeiro
acesso à energia que nós conhecemos e
que lhe damos hoje todos os dias e
continuamos em dúvida discutindo esse
tema e vamos continuar vamos continuar
discutindo esse tema o resto das nossas
vidas né na copa e 21 um acordo feito em
paris em 2015 que determina é de forma
mandatória o acesso à energia renovável
e os planos de descarbonização que são
ambiciosos certamente em alguns países
outros não mas que têm um papel muito
importante para a humanidade e para o
nosso futuro dos nossos filhos que a
gente imagina é hoje em dia talvez não
seja tão importante só que no dia a dia
isso faz parte de uma forma veemente a
nossa tomada de decisão e eu gostaria de
apresentar para vocês
esse granulado que parece ração de
cachorro que chama pet madeira o inglês
multiplex e é basicamente uma forma
engenheirada energética estratégica para
diminuir de forma mecânica pneumática os
índices de água de umidade dentro dessa
obra dessa maneira que a mesma maneira
do que o que o primeiro homem encontrou
porém com menos umidade e com maior
facilidade de aproveitamento pronta
nessa condição específica para
transporte e queima para geração de
energia
então é bom mas isso daí pode gerar
energia elétrica assim na realidade esse
plano de descarbonização da copa 21 tem
uma meta ambiciosa com relação à energia
renovável solar e eólica é intermitente
se tem só a gente tem essa energia se
não precisar de baterias e vocês
perceberam que uma bateria natural é a
madeira o sol proporciona essa energia
ea bateria é a madeira eólica se a gente
não tem vento durante a noite
a gente precisa também de uma bateria e
assim consequentemente as energias
renováveis
dependendo de alguma fonte alterna ou
alguma fonte de armazenamento pra poder
perdurar ao longo do tempo
então o que se espera da madeira disse
pet né
o que se espera de si permite que a
gente pode até ter uma menção da
biomassa que tem mais repercussão no
nosso país e no mundo é o etanol que é
um plano de sucesso que é um combustível
líquido que vem da cana porém existem
outros combustíveis e um deles é o pl
que se espera que 60% da redução de
biomassa no mundo da redução de
descarbonização com energia renovável no
mundo seja com madeira na forma de
hotéis onde na redução de carvão mineral
em termoelétricas que geram energia
elétrica
substituindo o carvão mineral em casas
nas residências em países europeus onde
esse índice de de calor é demandada por
volta de sete oito meses por ano por
questão do frio substituindo gás natural
então é um energético estratégico em nós
como país
temos um potencial enorme com relação a
isso eu e no meu doutorado eu fiquei
pensando bom se o potencial se encontra
em países tropicais como o brasil com a
problemática se a vantagem competitiva
se encontra em países tropicais como o
brasil e por sinal o nosso país
isso é uma questão específica não só por
ser um país tropical tem uma qualidade
com relação à produção por área de metro
quadrado de madeira maior que qualquer
outro país produtor de madeira
sustentável no mundo
e por que então que nós não inundamos o
mercado de pele de madeira né e não
entramos por uma incompetência
países tropicais que tem a luz do sol
abundante mas não tem a capacidade não o
contrário maior tecnologia do mundo hoje
em madeira se encontra o nosso país por
isso existe sim disse
porém a maior problemática foi a maior
problemática que me deparei na na
academia e no meu tempo de de estudante
de doutorado que foi descobrir por que é
que países tropicais eu sabia que na
vida nada é fácil e todo mundo sabe que
quando você vem de um lado você perde de
outro e é isso que é que a gente tem
aqui é a madeira cresce de forma
abundante em zonas tropicais
porém a chuva sublimação da chuva da
água e nessa nessas regiões
enquanto as taxas de cloro de saúde
cloro e esse saldo de cloro
consequentemente entrar no solo entrou
na biomassa ea madeira fica com altas
taxas de cloro coisa que outros países
não têm essa problemática porém o
crescimento reduzido por isso a gente
tem uma produção tão avantajada
comparada com o resto do mundo
então após a copa o problema do cloro
após a queima se formem dioxinas
organocoop organoclorado de forma
espontânea à madeira queima e ao se
transformar nesse composto químico ele é
comparado até com urânio pelas pelas
questões de de toxicidade que podem ser
letais
então aqui vem aquela questão é como
solucionar esse problema é seguir uma
uma expectativa somente de tentar ver
uma forma de solucionar sem nenhuma
pretensão somente de obter os louros em
sim de tentar atingir uma parte da
sociedade primeiro a nossa e quem sabe o
mundo eu acho que não existe limites pra
chegar onde a gente queira chegar
independente da área e em dois anos no
meio do doutorado conseguir fazer
patente eu com a ajuda de muitas pessoas
com muito trabalho eu não vou entrar em
detalhes mas a idéia básica é que a
patente ela foi a primeira feita fora do
país 148 países deu a liberação pra pra
fazer o depósito em 148 países no nosso
país como papel
de verde o método de remoção foi bem
sucedido com relação à análise da
patente então qual que é o gargalo o
ganho aqui né
se a gente tem uma madeira tradicional
com custos altos que não se enquadra no
padrão internacional
hoje com esse método nós podemos ter
pequenos produtores com resíduos de
madeira o pequena produção de maneira
independente dos desafios existentes
podem entrar no mercado internacional
com relação ao potencial que a gente
está vendo aqui
basicamente é esse mapa e também
desenvolver no doutorado mas é para
determinar mais - os índices com relação
ao nosso país só pra gente tem uma idéia
de imagem de grandeza de ordem de
grandeza
somente a 150 quilômetros do porto com
relação de logística produzir madeira em
área degradada dentro dos padrões da onu
dá com relação à a deslocamento de uso
do solo e eu falo do brasil não só
porque eu sou brasileiro e porque eu
acredito que o país tem grande potencial
nesse sentido e sim porque as condições
hoje estratégicas tanto florestais como
de biomassa na parte agrícola como
também na questão de expansão para
outros países na áfrica né e outros
países tropicais têm uma certa limitação
que hoje o país está preparado então o
brasil tem condições de chegar nesse
nesse nesse patamar de atendimento do
dessa energia renovável que se espera
tanto o brasil seria a menina dos olhos
vamos dizer assim com relação a isso
então somente a 150 quilômetros do porto
daria para produzir 40 milhões de
toneladas hoje se espera somente 4
milhões de toneladas no brasil e hoje o
país só exporta 12 mil toneladas não
chega nem a 100 mil toneladas de pedras
para exportação uma questão de preço
estratégico e vários outros pontos então
pra terminar
eu acredito que é entrar numa parte um
pouco mais romântica com relação ao
homem e à madeira seria o indicado mas
independente dos louros que eu ganhei
com relação a isso de prêmio de melhor
tese de doutorado na universidade de são
paulo teve excelente professor
isso tem muito tempo fora é impor conta
disso eu recebi um convite para estudar
na universidade de harvard nos estados
unidos que eu vou agora no final do ano
participo de relatórios internacionais
mas isso vem junto com qualquer sonho
que a gente tem
eu quero dizer pra vocês é que não se
limitem com relação à expectativa de
tomada de decisão nem chegar aonde vocês
acreditam que possam chegar porque da
mesma forma que esse homem começou de
uma forma primitiva em quem sabe no
futuro será da mesma maneira
[Aplausos]
[Música]